bon une fois n'est pas coutume j'ai
décidé de commencer l'année par un
épisode historiographique
c'est à dire un épisode qui parlera de
l'histoire de l'histoire
pourquoi on étudie tel sujet comment et
quels connaissant son entière bref la
discipline historique a bien évolué
depuis le 19e siècle dont on avait un
peu parlé dans l'épisode sur le roman
national
tout au début de la chaîne il ya
quelques temps je vous avais aussi parlé
de micro histoire à travers le livre le
plancher de joachim j'avais trouvé ça
passionnant et j'espère que vous aussi
l'historiographie est un sujet assez peu
connu du grand public
on pare chocs sur tout ça quand on est
en études d'histoire soi même donc il me
semblait intéressant de vous en parler
de temps en temps du coup aujourd'hui on
va parler d'histoire des femmes sujet ô
combien important sur bien des plans cet
épisode est dédié à tous ceux qui ne
trouvent trop féministe dans les
commentaires abonnez vous
[Musique]
et pour commencer pourquoi faire
l'histoire des femmes jusqu'à ce qu'on
s'intéresse à ce sujet l'histoire est
présentée comme général considérer comme
universelles c'est l'histoire des hommes
avec un grand h non pas comme ça aliénor
la différence des sexes n'est pas prise
en compte dans les discours mais occulte
dans les faits 50% de la population mise
à part quelques grandes figures comme
jeanne d'arc ou cléopâtre
on retrouve cette invisibilisation dans
des tas de sujets comme l'histoire du
droit de vote par exemple d'état
d'ouvragé narre la conquête du suffrage
universel en 1848 alors qu'il devient
vraiment universel qu'en 1944
cela peut s'expliquer par le fait que
l'histoire universitaire reste longtemps
une affaire d'hommes
écrite par des hommes et on reviendra là
dessus plus tard l'invisibilité des
femmes dans l'histoire est résumé par
virginia woolf dans son ouvrage une
chambre à soi paru en 1929 je
m'adressais à nouveau professeur
trevelyan pour savoir quelle était sa
conception de l'histoire
j'ai trouvé en regardant les têtes de
chapitres qu'il la comprenait ainsi la
cour du château et les méthodes de
culture en plein champ
les cisterciens à l'élevage des moutons
les croisades l'université la chambre
des communes la guerre de cent ans la
guerre des deux roses des érudits de la
renaissance la dissolution des
monastères le conflit agraire et
religieux l'origine de la puissance
maritime de l'angleterre la grande
armada etc
de temps en temps une femme précise et
mentionnait une elisabeth où le mari
stuart une reine ou une grande dame
mais jamais une femme de la classe
moyenne ayant à sa disposition que son
intelligence et son caractère n'a pu
participer à l'un quelconque des grands
mouvements qui rapprochait constitue la
vue de l'historien sur le passé et nous
ne trouverons pas non plus la femme dans
les collections d'anecdotes debré jamais
elle écrivait leur mémoire
rarement elle tard un journal on ne
possède qu'une poignée de lettres elle
ne les sert ni drame ni poèmes sur
lesquels nous puissions les juger ce
dont on a besoin pensais-je c'est une
masse de renseignements
et pourquoi quelques brillantes
étudiants donnent une âme de bertone ne
nous la procure va-t-il pas à quel âge
se marier tél à quoi ressemblait leur
maison dispose est telle d'une chambre à
elle
faisait thème la cuisine pouvait-elle
avoir une domestique toutes ces
précisions se trouve quelque part dans
les registres communaux et les livres de
comptes sans doute la vie de la femme
moyenne sous le règne d'elizabeth doit
être dispersée en de multiples endroits
ne pourrait-on pas rassemblé ses
éléments épars et en faire un livre
c'est là une ambition qui dépasse mon
audace pensais-je tout en cherchant sur
les rayons des livres qui ne s'y
trouvaient pas que de suggérer aux
étudiants de ces fameuses faculté de
réécrire l'histoire
il me semble pourtant bien reconnaître
que l'histoire telle qu'elle est me
semble un peu bizarre irréel et bâti de
guingois mais pourquoi n'ajouterai ton
pas un supplément à l'histoire
supplément auquel on donnerait bien
entendu un nom sans importance pour que
les femmes puissent y figurer sans
inconvenance me voici en train de me
demander pourquoi à l'époque
élisabéthaine les femmes n'écrivait pas
de poésie et je ne suis pas seulement
sur de la façon dont elles étaient
élevés leur apprenait-on à écrire
avait-elle un salon personnel
combien de femmes avait-elle des enfants
avant leur 21e année en un mot que
faisait tel de 8 heures du matin à huit
heures du soir
la volonté première des historiennes de
l'histoire des femmes et donc de faire
sortir les femmes de l'oubli de montrer
qu'elles ont une histoire souvent
différente des hommes est complémentaire
et qu'on ne peut considérer l'histoire
comme universel sans s'intéresser aussi
aux femmes ça paraît pourtant évident
dit comme ça mais ce n'est pas gagné
cette volonté et mage en même temps que
le courant historique de la nouvelle
histoire à partir des années 1960 qui
découle en partie de la colonisation et
s'intéresse aux marginaux groupes
minoritaires et opprimés aux exclus tout
comme les femmes représentent une
minorité sociale et économique
or l'histoire reste longtemps celle de
la majorité sociale et économique des
groupes dirigeants
le philosophe michel foucault par
exemple encourager la lecture de la
société à partir de ces exclus tu veux
aller d'or vous peut parler de toi
l'autre mouvement qui lance
définitivement l'histoire des femmes et
le féminisme
évidemment dans les années
d'après-guerre le décalage entre
l'histoire et la société en france et de
plus en plus flagrant après
l'acquisition du droit de vote la
création du planning familial la
démocratisation de l'enseignement
supérieur pour les femmes
la création du mlf en 1970 c'est
signifiante notamment la manifestation
du 26 août 1970 devant l'arc de triomphe
parmi les banderoles déployées on lit il
ya plus inconnu que le soldat inconnu
sa femme du coup l'histoire des femmes
découle d'une impulsion aussi bien
militante que scientifique
la première décennie de l'histoire des
femmes produit des travaux engagés sur
les mécanismes de la domination
masculine
la victimisation des femmes au cours de
l'histoire leur révolte l'historienne
françoise thébaud parle d'histoire du
malheur ces travaux sont principalement
écrits par des femmes engagées il existe
donc une complicité quasi inédite entre
le sujet et son hôte rice d'une manière
générale il existe toujours un rapport
entre l'historien ou l'historienne et le
sujet choisi conscient affirmé ou non
mais c'est la première fois que cette
proximité est autant revendiquer
l'histoire des femmes et le premier
champ historique à être autant lié à un
mouvement social avec l'histoire
ouvrière certes ces enjeux sont de
légitimer le mouvement féministe en
faisant valoir les passes et des femmes
et de justifier les revendications de
l'époque cette nouvelle histoire qu'on
ait des résistances bien sûr laura lee
downs qui enseigne l'histoire des femmes
en 1989 aux états unis témoigne de
l'exaspération d'une partie de ces
étudiants chaque fois qu'elle aborde le
sujet convaincu que ces détours vers
l'histoire des femmes l'épreuve d'une
partie de la vraie histoire
rebecca rogers se raconte dans les
années 90 que certains de ces étudiants
écrivent en bas de leur évaluation
je ne sais pas pourquoi on est obligé
d'écouter cette féministe marxiste c'est
l'homme paulo en france françoise
thébaud perçoit surtout de l'étonnement
de la part de certains élèves qui lui
reprochent de sortir de la discipline
historique niche un twist of fate et bit
ly speaking hugh jackman avec jenny wind
river bestech les homos manager in show
michel pébereau pionnière de l'histoire
des femmes en france écrit dans l'un de
ses ouvrages femmes en murray comment
vous rejoindre en effet écrire
l'histoire des femmes nécessite de
repenser totalement les sources sur
lesquelles s'appuient les historiens
habituellement longtemps exclue de la
sphère publique les femmes n'ont pas
laissé de trace dans les archives
diplomatiques administrative dans la
presse et quand elles en ont laissé ces
documents parfois été mal catalogué
détruit la conservation des archives
n'étant pas neutres dans le cadre de la
commune de paris par exemple les
dossiers judiciaires des hommes ont été
beaucoup mieux conservées que ceux des
femmes bien que seuls 15 mille dossiers
de communards survivre sur un total
d'environ 40000 les dossiers de non lieu
ont tous été détruits en 1936 par un
archiviste qu'il est jugé inutile
concernant les femmes les dossiers ont
simplement disparu sauf celui de louise
michel en 1964 dans le procès de
communards de jacques rougerie
l'auteur de consacre qu'une petite
partie aux femmes juste avant les
enfants
considérant qu'elles n'étaient pas assez
nombreuses pour faire l'objet de la même
analyse que les hommes
on sait maintenant que c'est très loin
de la réalité en 1982 à force de travail
à la bibliothèque historique de la ville
de paris l'historienne maltais a bisto
rassemble des milliers de documents sur
l'histoire des femmes qui n'avaient
jamais été inventoriés en travaillant
sur les archives les historiennes de
l'histoire des femmes doivent poser un
regard nouveau sur les documents à leur
disposition elle constate alors que les
archives ne sont pas si mu est que ça
les archives policières et judiciaires
par exemple font parler les femmes anne
marie saône se sert de ces documents en
1996 dans sa thèse sur le rôle des
femmes dans la vie privée par exemple la
plupart des sources peuvent aussi être
lue en creux et faire alors surgir le
regard porté sur les femmes laura lee
doses qui travaille sur les femmes
ouvrières explique ainsi qu'elle les a
longtemps cru non qualifiés pour la
simple raison qu'elles étaient toutes
rassemblées au même endroit dans les
archives tandis que les hommes étaient
divisés entre qualifiés semi qualifiés
et non qualifiés se trouve qu'en fait
ces femmes étaient pour la plupart
qualifier joanne kelly spécialiste de la
renaissance raconte que lorsqu'elle est
sollicitée en 1971 pour participer à un
cours sur l'histoire des femmes elle
répond d'abord qu'elle n'a rien à dire
puis après quelques jours de réflexion
et de reconsidération des livres et des
documents à sa disposition
elle se rend compte que d'histoire
qu'elle donne de la renaissance et
déformés et incomplètes et développe un
cours les femmes ont elles connu une
renaissance
l'histoire des femmes tout comme
l'histoire culturelle à la même période
contribuer à élargir la notion de
sources s'appuie aussi sur la presse les
correspondances les livres de compte les
journaux intimes qui sont de moins en
moins rare à partir du 19ème siècle
c'est archi familiale et archives de soi
met du temps à s'imposer mais sont
maintenant reconnus comme des documents
utiles à la recherche historique même si
jusqu'au début du 20e siècle
ils sont surtout le fruit 2000
aisés ou militants d'autres historiens
s'intéresse à l'image des femmes dans la
symbolique religieuse républicaine
l'histoire des représentations est utile
de l'histoire des femmes mathilde du
bcsa plus par exemple dans ses
recherches sur les photographies
d'ouvrières ou d'employés à
saint-etienne dans la première moitié du
20e siècle pour révéler les normes
postural de chaque sexe et la valeur
attribuée aux tâches des uns et des
autres l'histoire du temps présent
s'appuie aussi sur le cinéma et les
sources audiovisuelles depuis les années
1990 enfin une belle histoire orale qui
émergent dans les années 60
en même temps que l'histoire des femmes
le recours aux témoignages apparaît
d'abord en grande bretagne et en italie
permettant de faire surgir une histoire
populaire construite à partir du point
de vue de ceux qui sont dominés ses
premiers représentants en france sont
par exemple jacques ozouf qui travaille
sur les instituteurs du début du 20e
siècle les sources orales permettent de
rendre compte de l'expérience de groupe
absent des documents écrits mais
rencontre un accueil mitigé d'abord on
se questionne sur la pertinence
d'interroger un destin individuel par
rapport à l'analyse de centaines de
documents écrit l'histoire des
mentalités n'en est qu'à ses débuts
aussi on remet en cause la fiabilité de
ces sources sera le basé sur la mémoire
et souvent recueilli longtemps après les
faits évoqués les personnes interrogées
sont elles vraiment capable de se
rappeler fidèlement les évènements
décrits des psychologues qui ont
travaillé sur la question ont démontré
que c'est au contraire dans les jours
qui suivent un événement que la mémoire
rejette la plus grande quantité
d'informations et que les souvenirs se
fixe par la suite il prouve aussi que la
mémoire des personnes âgées n'est pas
moins fiables que celles de jeunes
adultes
il remarque aussi cependant que la
mémoire est un mélange de vécu et da
prix devraient et d'imaginaire et que
certains témoins ont tendance à
rapporter des mythes entourant des
grands événements comme s'il les avait
vécu ou à raconter des événements en
réalité vécue par leur parrain le
souvenir joue un grand rôle aussi on a
plus tendance à se rappeler d'un
événement public s'il est lié à quelque
chose de personnel
la date d'un mariage par exemple les
chercheuses qui interviewent des femmes
remarque en effet quel reconstruisent la
trame de leur vie en se référant à la
naissance de leurs enfants à la mort
d'un proche et non aux grands événements
historiques
sauf s'ils ont perturbé leur quotidien
l'assassinât de montereau connais pas
est ce que je vous ai parlé du 10
septembre 1419 où j'ai cueilli un
champignon cependant les chercheurs paul
thompson et alessandro portelli démontre
que l'écrit n'est pas plus objectif que
l'oral déjà parce que les documents
écrits dont sont souvent qu'une
transcription de l'or
incluant la perception des événements
qu'on avait l'auteur ensuite parce qu'il
s'écoule aussi souvent un laps de temps
entre l'événement et sa mise par écrit
et césar vainquit les sauvages gaulois
moustachu dépanner au 1er siècle après
jésus-christ twh
et puis comme on l'a vu les documents
écrits ont plus souvent tendance à
occulter des femmes de l'histoire
l'histoire des femmes tout comme
l'histoire culturelle et l'histoire des
mentalités permet donc un formidable
renouveau du rapport des historiens aux
sources
à partir des années 70 qui bénéficie à
toutes les disciplines comme le dit
michel perron en 1975
l'histoire des femmes demande de
l'ingéniosité pour pallier la pauvreté
des sources classiques les méthodes de
cette histoire devrait emprunter
beaucoup à l'ethnologie aussi bien pour
le déchiffrement des mythologiques pour
l'exploration du quotidien comme elle
elle devra user de la quête du récit à
la manière des anglo saxons beaucoup
plus avancés que nous dans cette
direction de l'histoire orale
enfin l'histoire des femmes devraient
réaffirmer sans cesse sa problématique
qui est la recherche obstinée d'une
relation à l'autre sexe et à l'histoire
globale dans la première partie même si
j'ai commencé à parler de l'émergence de
l'histoire des femmes dans les années 70
je voulais surtout vous expliquer
pourquoi elle émerger et maintenant on
va voir plus concrètement comment elle
prend vie il trouve sa place dans les
institutions historiques on trouve des
précurseurs de l'histoire des femmes
avant les années 70 christine de pisan
voire même emilia passano dont je vous
parlais dans le dernier gentes dames
plata ce célèbre dans leurs écrits les
grandes dames du passé et revendiquent
leur place dans l'histoire
en 1804 fortunés briques et rédige
également le dictionnaire historique des
françaises les vies de saints sont aussi
courante à cette époque
d'une manière générale les travaux sur
les femmes 19e siècle sont surtout
biographique ils peuvent viser à montrer
la supériorité morale des femmes ou à
mettre en avant certaines personnalités
comme marie antoinette ou sainte claire
d'assise
d'autres travaux s'intéressent déjà à la
vie quotidienne et à la mentalité de
certaines populations dont les femmes
c'est le cas des travaux de lucie menad
salman par exemple méprisé par la
profession qui qualifie ces recherches
d'histoire d'arrière-cour les différents
courants historiques qui se succèdent à
partir du 19ème siècle l'école
méthodique les annales l'histoire
quantitative exclut les femmes et
dimension sexuelle de leur champ de
recherche
pire encore il un visibilis le travail
de certaines historienne simone vidal
ac épouse de marc bloch n'est jamais
mentionnée dans les travaux de son mari
bien qu'elles l'aident dans ses
recherches et ses relectures de
manuscrits suzanne faivre agrégé
d'histoire arrêt son doctorat dès son
mariage pour élever ses enfants aient
assisté son mari qui devient dans des
historiens les plus connus du 20e siècle
lucien favre prend également comme
assistante lucie varga docteur en
histoire du moyen-âge et bonne
observatrice du nazisme qui est l'une
des deux seules femmes a signé des
articles dans la revue des annales avant
mais elle est mise de côté par lucien
febvre apparemment à cause de sa passion
décembre pour elle doit abandonner ses
recherches et meurt en 1941 à 36 ans la
deuxième femme à être publiés dans les
annales thérèse sclafer et médiéviste
mais n'occupe pas de poste universitaire
la première thèse soutenue par une femme
remonte à 1923 il s'agit d'un doctorat
ès lettres avec spécialisation histoire
soutenu par madeleine dernier ce qui
meurt un an après sa soutenance et
sombre donc dans l'oubli les premières
thèses sur l'histoire des femmes
remontent aux années 1930 et sont le
fruit d'hommes et de femmes proches des
mouvements féministes et dit thomas par
exemple rédige des biographies de femmes
révolutionnaires dans les années 1950
aux états unis le développement de
l'histoire des femmes est plus aisé
grâce au système universitaire de
petites universités pour femmes existent
dès le 19ème siècle souvent sur le même
campus que les grandes universités dont
elles sont des annexes
de plus le féminisme n'a pas la même
signification aux états unis qu'en
france où il évoque souvent des
positions extrémistes vis-à-vis des
hommes
les fameuses femina site twitter se dire
féministe aux états unis exposants bien
moins à toutes sortes d'idées reçues
on comprend que le pays soit un terreau
beaucoup plus favorable développement de
l'histoire des femmes à partir des
années 1960 à cette époque donc on ne
dénombre que trois femmes sur 120
professeurs d'histoire en france les
mouvements sociaux aux états unis sont
suivies en europe des grèves et
mouvements étudiant de mai 68 les états
unis et la grande bretagne sont donc
pionnier en histoire des femmes avec le
pour dit oui mais n'avait connaissance
de john kelly en 1972 les premiers
centres de recherche sur l'histoire des
femmes sont fondées dans des universités
publiques et privées
le premier étant le mari ibrahim bunting
institute en 1960
fondée au radcliffe college
pendant féminin de harvard un institute
for research on women and gender est
fondé à standford en 1974 le
développement de ces centres plus rapide
qu'en france est permis par le
financement privé sur lequel reposent
ces universités en france les pionnières
de l'histoire des femmes sont des
sociologues qui s'intéressent au travail
des femmes le développement de
l'histoire des femmes s'accompagne de
l'arrivée de femmes dans la discipline
quatre d'entre elles sont nommées
professeur d'histoire contemporaine en
1970 dont michelle perrot qui s'engagent
dans l'histoire des femmes en 1971 en
compte autant d'hommes que de femmes
reçues à l'agrégation d'histoire et en
1974 de concours devient mixte
les premiers cours d'histoire des femmes
sont mis en place en 1973 le premier
étant donnée par michel perron et ayant
pour titre les femmes ont-elles une
histoire non titre qui montre bien le
manque de connaissances encore criants
dans cette discipline à ses débuts
l'histoire des femmes utilisent beaucoup
le même schéma de confiscation du
pouvoir des femmes par les hommes mais
en y apportant nuance hercules les
historiennes met très tôt en avant la
scientificité de leur démarche et la
reconnaissance par des institutions
scientifiques se fait donc en douceur
la première revue d'histoire des femmes
pénélope est créée en 1979 mais disparu
en 1985 phoques de soutien
institutionnel en 1970 l'histoire reste
partagée entre l'histoire économique et
sociale promue par les annales et
l'histoire événementielle politique
militaire diplomatique
cependant de nouveaux courants
historiques apparaissent histoire décor
de la maladie de la mort des
comportements sexuels à cette époque
l'histoire s'ouvre vers d'autres
disciplines
la sociologie et l'anthropologie par
exemple on parle alors de nouvelles
histoires des courants semblables se
retrouve dans tous les pays en italie
avec la micro histoire dont j'ai déjà
parlé ou en allemagne avec l'histoire du
quotidien par exemple dans ce contexte
différent champ d'étude en histoire des
femmes émerge l'un des premiers et la
question du travail des femmes du
rapport entre femmes et mouvement
ouvrier
contrairement à ce qu'on pensait
auparavant l'industrialisation au 19e
siècle ne provoque pas de rupture pour
les femmes au niveau travail et famille
mais on constate plutôt une continuité
avec l'ancienne économie rurale
on constate aussi la méfiance des
mouvements ouvriers français envers le
travail des femmes craignant la
concurrence de ces travailleuses
elles sont d'ailleurs assez peu impliqué
dans les révoltes ouvrières bien sûr je
ne vais pas pouvoir vous raconter tous
les aspects de tous les champs de
recherche de l'histoire des femmes
le but étant ici de vous montrer
quelques exemples d'études l'histoire
des femmes est très tôt l' histoire d
oppression et des transgressions
certaines listes
elle s'intéresse ainsi aux héros est une
féministe grévistes qui milite au 19e
siècle contre l'ordre établi
michel perron résume ses recherches en
1987 l'histoire des femmes a d'abord été
celle de leur oppression femmes battues
trompée humiliée et violée sous paient
abandonné faut les enfermer
on a fait l'inventaire des malheurs
féminin sans toujours s'interroger sur
des mécanismes de la domination en
envoyant plutôt les effets histoire
nécessaire mais déprimante aussi
évidemment l'histoire des femmes n'est
pas l'histoire du féminisme mais le
féminisme fait partie des sujets abordés
le genre biographique qui a longtemps
été une composante centrale de
l'histoire fait aussi l'objet d'un fort
renouveau des biographies de militantes
ou d'intellectuels du 19e au 20e siècle
sont rédigées un peu ce qu'on fait avec
les gentes dames badass
on parle de moi la fonction de ses
biographies et de montrer que les femmes
sont autant capables que les hommes de
faire de l'histoire et de reproduire la
dimension épique de l'histoire en
opposant aux exploits d'hommes des
exploits de femmes de plus en plus de
tests dieter des femmes portent sur une
seule ou quelques femmes au delà de ces
révoltes individuelles d'autres
historienne s'intéresse aux résistances
diffuse des femmes alors lieu de
sociabilité le marché le lavoir le four
les associations et congrégations
féminines mais aussi les participations
aux émeutes et aux grèves
un autre champ d'étude important à
l'histoire de la famille et des
sexualités étudié du point de vue des
femmes c'est le cas des news mclaren qui
étudient l'avortement 19e siècle par
exemple l'histoire des corps est
également très répandue l'activité des
femmes au sein de la maison au moment de
l'héritage leurs activités économiques
dans la famille constitue de nombreux
sujets d'étude à toutes les périodes
l'éducation des femmes est également
abordée en 1976 françoise meyers
soutient une thèse sur l'enseignement
secondaire des jeunes filles au 19e
siècle de la création des cours du ruy à
l'alignement des enseignements
secondaires masculin et féminin en 1924
au-delà de ces champs de recherche
l'histoire des femmes permet de remettre
en cause la chronologie établie depuis
longtemps en histoire d'un succession de
règne de régime et la division entre
antiquité moyen-âge époque moderne et
contemporaine perd encore plus de sens
si on considère l'histoire du point de
vue féminin joanne kelly conclu son
cours sur la renaissance en expliquant
que les femmes ne l'ont pas
connu du moins pas pendant la période
nommé durant la première guerre mondiale
hommes et femmes vivent deux chronologie
du conflit départ à la guerre versus
attentes en 1914 enlisement dans les
tranchées versus mise au travail dans
les usines en 1915 en 1994
françoise thébaud interroge la
libération de 1945 en se demandant si
les femmes ont vraiment bénéficié de la
révolution politique sociale et
économique qui accompagne cette période
même si elles obtiennent le droit de
vote ne peuvent pas être élu elle ne se
libèrent socialement qu'à partir des
années 1960
de nos jours l'histoire des femmes s'est
encore élargi n'hésitant pas par exemple
à s'intéresser des postures considérées
comme négatives comme la violence des
femmes ou les femmes dans la
collaboration
à ce titre la violence des femmes a
longtemps été sous-évalués beaucoup de
femmes étant acquittée de leur crime car
considérées comme mineures ou encore
parce que ces femmes source de fécondité
ne méritait pas les mêmes peines que les
hommes
certains champs de recherche se sont
aussi déplacés de l'exploration des
femmes dans la sphère privée dans les
années 70 et 80
on est passé à une étude de la sphère
publique ou à l'accès à la citoyenneté
des femmes leurs droits politiques etc
l'histoire du travail s'est aussi tourné
de lusine vers d'autres corps de métier
mais femme institutrice infirmière
enseignante d'autres champs restent peu
étudié l'histoire du travail des femmes
dans les champs justement où dans
l'artisanat et des boutiques
d'autres historiens étudie le rapport au
genre dans les territoires villes et
campagnes dans la laïcité la
colonisation les sciences et savoir les
identités le développement de l'histoire
des femmes a permis l'émergence de
l'histoire du genre sujet de plus on
peut étudier dans les universités anglo
saxonnes à partir des années 80 le genre
gender désigne le sexe social est le
rapport entre les sexes sujets abordés
par l'histoire des femmes dès ses débuts
il est théorisée par des sociologues à
la fin des années 60 et dépend des
constructions sociales des rolls a signé
des activités des croyances
à la différence du sexe qui est beaucoup
plus fixe jo ann scott en propose la
définition suivante
le genre est un élément constitutif des
rapports sociaux fondés sur des
différences perçu entre les sexes et le
genre est une façon première de
signifier des rapports de pouvoir
cette notion n'est même pas récente
certains auteurs de traités de médecine
aux 16e et 17e siècles distinguait déjà
le sexe organes de la reproduction du
genre qui englobait les
ference corporelle et morale en gros on
passe d'une histoire considérer comme
universelles mais qu'ils ignoraient les
femmes à une histoire des femmes puis à
une histoire vraiment universelle cette
fois qui tient compte du fait qu'il
existe des hommes et des femmes avec
tous les rapports sociaux
ça implique en france le terme est peu
utilisé jusqu aux années 2000 on préfère
parler de rapports de sexe ou tout
simplement de sexe le terme de ge en
restant largement incompris les éditeurs
ne sont pas très chauds pour l'utiliser
la table ronde de 1993 sur le genre de
la protection est publié sous le titre
différence des sexes et protection
sociale la gender istrie permet pourtant
de reconsidérer des événements et
phénomène historique l'histoire du
travail ouvrier féminin par exemple est
progressivement remplacé par une
histoire sexuée du travail ouvrier qui
montre la manière dont la différence
sexuelle façonnent les relations dans
l'entreprise
la gender qui tue et s'intéresse aussi à
des sujets nouveaux sylvie steinberg
étudie ainsi le travestissement au
moyen-âge et à l'époque moderne
la notion de genre permet de se rendre
compte que si on peut faire de
l'histoire des femmes à partir d'une
histoire qui ont considéré comme neutre
jusque là on peut aussi faire de
l'histoire des hommes
leymen studies apparaissent à la fin des
années 70 étudiants par exemple la
masculinisation de la symbolique
ouvrière la paternité la virilité la vie
et les sentiments des soldats durant la
grande guerre etc
de nos jours l'histoire des femmes et
donc davantage reconnu il ya même fait
des émules avec la gender istres et la
parution de l'histoire des femmes en
occident de georges duby michelle perrot
en 1990 est l'un des témoins de cette
reconnaissance
dans l'introduction les auteurs
rappellent le titre histoire des femmes
en occident et commode est beau mais il
faut récusé l'idée que les femmes
seraient en elle-même un objet
d'histoire c'est leur place leur
condition leur rôle et leur pouvoir leur
forme d'actions leur silence et leur
paroles que nous entendons scruter la
diversité de leurs représentations ds
madone sorcières que nous voulons saisir
dans leur permanence et leur changement
l'histoire des femmes a essaimé dans
d'autres pays à partir des années 90 la
chine le maghreb ou l'europe de l'est
par exemple
l'europe fournit toujours la majorité
des adhérents à la fédération
internationale pour la recherche en
histoire des femmes mais celle ci
regroupe maintenant tous les continents
l'apparition de revues spécialisées clio
en 1985 genre et histoire en 2007 pour
ne citer que quelques revues françaises
montre aussi l'intérêt grandissant pour
ce champ de recherche a là encore les
pays anglo saxons ont une longueur
d'avancé
en 1993 la bibliothèque universitaire de
weeds consignes recense 114 revue de
women's studies dont beaucoup sont
consacrés à l'histoire pour désigner
l'histoire des femmes les pays anglo
saxons crée même dans les années 80 le
néologisme de hearst auraient
difficilement traduisible en français ce
sont aussi les pays anglophones qui
popularise la métaphore de la visibilité
et donc de l'invisibilité des femmes en
histoire jusqu aux années 70 enfin le
dynamisme de l'histoire des femmes dans
ces pays s'explique par le fait que les
historiennes anglo saxonnes ont pu créer
de nouvelles institutions sur ces sujets
alors que les historiennes françaises
ont plutôt cherché à rentrer dans les
institutions déjà existantes et souvent
réticentes l'institut emilie du châtelet
qui vise à développer et diffuser les
recherches sur les femmes le sexe et le
genre n'est créée qu'en 2006 trente ans
après le début de l'histoire des femmes
en france depuis les années 2000 les
associations se développe cependant
comme mnémosyne qui organise colloques
et journées d'étude la présence des
femmes dans les métiers de l'histoire a
également évolué 41% des maîtres de
conférences et 27 % des professeurs sont
des femmes
bien qu'elle soit moins présentes en
histoire moderne et contemporaine des
inégalités existent toujours bien sûr le
choix entre faire des enfants à faire
une carrière se pose toujours plus pour
les femmes que pour les hommes et les
logiques relationnel au sein des
institutions universitaires maintiennent
des inégalités en faveur des hommes des
historiennes comme arlette farge michel
perron sont désormais des grands noms de
l'histoire en france mais elles ont dû
se battre dans les années 80 pour
imposer leur champ de recherche et leur
légitimité
elles ont été aidées par le grand public
aussi qui montre de plus en plus
d'intérêt pour les études de genre dont
plus merci à vous et merci d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo dont j'ai hâte de
lire les commentaires
c'est de l'ironie j'espère que cette
approche historiographique du sujet vous
a intéressé c'était beaucoup de travail
pour synthétiser tout ça comme
d'habitude vous pouvez vous abonner
j'ai commenté maître dé pouce en l'air
et si vous le souhaitez vous pouvez
contribuer au financement de mes vidéos
sur tipi ou sur youtube par des dons ou
visionnage de pub
les liens sont dans la description jeu
mais aussi comme d'habitude dans la
description toutes les références
bibliographiques qui m'ont permis de
composer ce sujet et que vous pouvez
aller fouiller une mauvaise je profite
aussi de la fin de cette vidéo pour vous
parler de médiéval tv si vous n'avez pas
vu passer l'info il s'agit d'une
plateforme de vod c'est à dire de
diffusion en streaming style d'un flic
ce qui fonctionne sur abonnement et qui
se lancent actuellement elle
elle parlera exclusivement de moyen-âge
je suis dedans j'ai une émission compte
aussi par exemple nota bene hugo de
confession d'histoire plein de gens
vraiment bien donc voilà si le sujet
vous intéresse je vous invite à vous
rendre sur médiévale tv pareil je vais
mettre le lien dans la description et
voilà vous pourrez vous abonner si vous
le souhaitez je vous retrouve le mois
prochain pour un jean todt i'm bad ass
puis le mois d'après pour un chronique
de profs commence à connaître la routine
et en attendant vous portez vous bien et
à bientôt
voilà qui s'entassent et les femmes qui
font battre une histoire depuis la nuit
des temps les femmes
nous sommes celles qu'on ne voit écrit
quatre histoires construisant aux
espoirs
un parvis les fans à genève en duo les
dans toutes les maisons et femmes du
monde
[Musique]
le vent de face en orage et brisant
toutes les guerres
deux m'ont tellement de boue
le temps de la colère les frères nôtre
est arrivé que les sons
les fans mécontents ou détenir écrire
notre histoire
[Musique]
construisant nos espoirs